je joue la cage aux folles mille fois à
peu près et y avait quelqu'un qui jouait
une scène là dedans c'est une scène très
drôle du boucher il arrivait le boucher
en disant tu procèdes constructeurs puis
on sentait que au fur et à mesure et
donner la recette
il était un peu d'eux ils étaient un peu
teinté si j'ose dire il s'est tu prends
ton beefsteak
et puis tu vend des pizzas et puis après
quand tu continues quand c'est cuit
alors c'est peut-être cette année là
c'est pas moi l'auteur ses jambes
c'était très drôle cette fête qui
portait magnifique mais le mec il
n'avait qu'une scène
c'est dire qu'il n'écoutait plus du tout
il descendit regarder le foot dans sa
télé un vaisseau vers les désordres et
et puis vu il fait l'équipe
il me coupais c'est à dire j'avais même
pas le temps de respirer georges eden il
n'écoutait pas ce que je disais et un
jour parce que je suis pas méchante et
sa maman sont au bout d'un moment quand
je sens bien une bonne scène kalima
jouer ça me fait chier quand gbagbo
alors je dis je lui dis donc en
continuant de jouer dans le personnage
judic auto c'est pas grave tu parles
trop vite devant les gens ouais devant
le studio les ans l'open je faisais avec
un tel culot en jouant le personnage
toujours j'ai pas dis que tu me fais
chier et herat dont tu dis tu parles tu
parles trop vite tu jures savent que tu
me regardes tu vas regarde quand je te
pose la question tu respires et écoute
et puis tu me réponds mais c'est pas
grave kockott puisque je jouais non
c'est pas pour elle pourra le refaire
on la refait en scène ça comme ça et
j'avais un tel culot ça dépasse mes
intentions
les gens se sont aperçus de rien ils ont
cru que j'étais dans la pièce ja oui
comment tu veux la jouer le personnage
de [ __ ] dure comme ça tu peux pas le
faire comme ça
aujourd'hui tu fais comme non c'est
aujourd'hui le cas si de lumut comme tu
le faisais dans la cage aux folles
oui ça ya 25 ans l'un pourquoi
s'est-elle il laisse et puis ça n'existe
plus c'est fini nous on a connu ça parce
que dans les cabarets on a connu un tas
de gens l'antiquaire que c'est quelle
gentillesse comme auxerre ont fait la
cage aux folles ça vient du skate jeune
antiquaire absolument mais maintenant
maintenant les personnages qu'on use
them n'existe plus il y avait des
références forcément mais avec je vais
pas chez tonton tu as connu de
l'histoire d'angola lors c'était
formidable
c'est michou et alors mais c'était très
troublant parce que j'en avais beaucoup
de visites de gens qui venaient dans les
loges et au départ dont on avait été je
veux dire tous les homos de paris il y
avait des copains loeb dont il était
contre le penser et dire on se foutent
de nous ils vont se [ __ ] de zéro il ya
plein de mecs qui venait de voir en
disant il faut pas le faire il faut pas
le faire non seulement mais des gens qui
nous parlaient plus d'écho peur et puis
au fur et à mesure qu'ils ont ils ont vu
ce qui se passait c'est à dire que
c'était ne trouvais pas ça ridicule et
moi j'ai eu dans ma loge des gens
ciné et quand il se met en rose et quand
il se prostituer téhéran a encore mieux
en bonnes femmes qu'avec ton texte on
sait faire
c'était france et de l'allemagne
tous ces cas là qu'on sait pas par
exemple c'est que en italie puisqu'il y
avait bien dit que les mains à ses
succès et bien le succès s'est pas fait
sur l'énormité la drôlerie mais sur
l'émotion et les gens pleuraient
peut-être les médecins il faisait très
comme ça aussi mais c'était l'auto
dérision oui n'ont pu y avait un autre
on était tous des anciens c'était la
situation impossible à vivre et bien
d'un mix ford le personnage on lesquels
le mec qui vive on va recevoir le fils
mais il faut que tu te mettre en bonne
parce qu'on veut parra va pas dire qu'on
est alors l'outil du bain je peux aussi
au mas biya comme un homme habillé comme
un veston mais gardez des choses est
trop donc que des trucs comme ça
et alors c'était pathétique c'était vrai
c'était humain mais tu sais que même
quand je fais le clown au cirque 1 il ya
des moments de vérité qui qui sont
payants faut pas tricher est vraiment
quand je dis on blague à un jeune
comédien scotia bien voir ce qu'il y
avait michel dans le film d'avoir géré à
un bien et rennes tu es vachement bien
ouais tu veux pas de voir je comprends
pas
mais avec nous non allez voir c'est fini
d'ailleurs souffert mais voilà c'est pas
de risques devenues des décors superbes
mais je suis aussi patricia la voilà
c'est ça qui est merveilleux chez vous
mais moi dans la chambre c'est vrai mais
chef la jambe allait alors vous savez
que j'ai perdu mon frère
oui j'aimerais enfin le père 90 110 je
tiens à l'enterrement
mais alors que michel blanc un
changement
givens interne chez moi ce que t'as
foutu français jette une connerie mais
on n'y est pas ce n'est pas notre métier
n'est pas qu'il faut que je travaille
c'est la fin de la première partie
je suis quelqu'un de projecteur sur la
baie
tout jeune j'ai du mal à trouver les
sous
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu